the Arctic Ocean down below looks gray
and choppy as if it was frozen mid swell
we're heading with Russia's Ministry of
Defence touka tell me island a closed
military zone in the new siberian island
range of Russia's Arctic coastline
[Music]
I'm here
[Music]
a lot of them are smaller facilities but
our destination is an actual base
northern clover it's called windswept
bleak and combat-ready that's Russia's
Panther S anti-aircraft system specially
modified for arctic conditions our
division is here to keep radar control
of airspace and to control the northern
sea routes Russia wants to defend
against any potential plundering of its
natural resources and it hopes to
benefit from an increase in commercial
shipping as the Arctic warms but
analysts I spoke to in Moscow say the
premise is flawed for it rather far from
reality about warming and our treasures
because if warning is a truth all
infrastructure on all course will
disappear very quickly but for NATO a
militaries Russian Arctic coincides with
a more assertive Russia elsewhere enough
against its northern flank a Russia's
Arctic based nuclear assets including 12
strategic nuclear submarines Russia
insists that it's military buildup in
the Arctic is purely defensive in nature
and the Arctic at the moment is still a
place of relatively low tension but it's
quite clear that Russia can escalate
that as soon as it feels that it's
interested to threatened as NATO and
Russia sized up each other's
capabilities in the high north the UK is
set to announce a new Arctic strategy
which will see annual cold weather
training for the Royal Marines with
Norway and the introduction of new
submarine hunting aircraft a lot more
action than these Russian troops say
they expect to see and who do you
consider your greatest enemy up here in
the Arctic
or water enemy the weather we don't have
any other enemies here we protect
ourselves for the weather conditions and
we do our service for the benefit of the
state all players in the Arctic hope
it'll stay that way
but with Russia more than happy to flex
its muscles elsewhere no one is taking
chances
Diana Magnay from kotomi island in the
Russian Arctic